[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Jack be nimble Jack be quick
Jack
indict this brick
oh boy Jack Smith is moving in on him
like a [__]
[__] ass [__] to be exact I don't mean
to be so vulgar or maybe I do I'm just
[__] you I definitely mean to be
that vulgar
so it appears that uh Donald Trump and
his his attorney
um who the Jack Smith and the special
counsel have asked to the courts to take
the crime fraud exception uh went to the
appeals court now they're gonna they're
gonna yell and scream we're gonna hear
this today this is gonna be I'm telling
you already I know exactly what the [__]
manga is going to be saying I already
know it
they're going to be saying oh it's all
rigged it's an Obama and Biden judge
it's a bunch of Democrats which they
don't know that the last appeal that the
[__] idiot lost it was Trump judges
and Bush judges and this is how the
courts work you don't get to pick your
judges generally speaking especially in
appeals it's like a straw you draw
straws and that's what you get
so because he drew the wrong straws here
but the thing is is the timing on this
apparently they put a stay on the crime
fraud exception because they want a
documents or some documents it's unclear
exactly what the documents that they
want
um and the doj had six hours and Trump
had six hours to our Trump had six hours
to to get the documents together and and
the doj had six hours until six am it's
fast it's [__] fast and the legal
analysis is is that it's never been this
fast some people are saying it's because
Trump
uh all's he does is delay delay delay
some are worried that it might be a
national security
um risk which I mean it's not far out of
the question is it who knows what the
[__] documents this guy still had he had
the laptop from Mattel he's been telling
us that he had the laptop from hell he
had the thumb drive from hell they were
they were xeroxing and putting digital
copies on laptops and thumb drives who
knows if that thumb drive made it into
Jared kushner's pocket and made it over
to the world cup with Elon and the
Saudis who knows who could possibly know
where those Secrets have gone and who
has them and who he sold them to or who
he traded for something I don't know who
the [__] knows who the [__] knows sounds
like Jack Smith knows hmm
hmm I don't know now the the word is the
reason why this crime fraud exception
is because
um Donald Trump misled his attorney no
[__] Sherlock are you [__] kidding me
are we supposed to sit here and listen
to the media go did you know Donald
Trump misleads people especially his
attorneys yeah no [__] kidding
are you serious have you been listening
to what the [__] has been happening with
this with this stupid ass narrative
around the Manhattan DA's case Jesus
Christ every [__] we I was in a space
yesterday again a Twitter space and yet
again yesterday and these [__] manga
idiots these Ultra manga idiots they're
self-proclaimed manga Nation like these
aren't people like well I'm not exactly
for Trump no they're [__] they're
simps they're [__] cultist
they're like here is one of the
arguments here's one of the [__]
craziest arguments that was being made
that it's the hush money payment is not
illegal
who gives a [__] about the hush money
payment no one not not a single media
outlet that is serious has been
reporting that they think the charges
around the actual payment itself
it's not the it's never it's never the
[__] thing that that Trump tries to
do it's the crime he commits trying to
do it
it's it's absolutely [__]
mind-boggling that we can't break
through these folks we cannot break
through and again you know they're
[__] deluded they're they're they're
mind [__] what are we supposed to do
besides just move forward do what you're
supposed to do hold these [__]
accountable the other argument that I
get because they kept saying that he's
not he has no criminal history bull
[__] [__] Donald Trump's organization
along with Alan weisselberg his CFO
was charged and convicted with crimes in
the state of New York 17 criminal counts
to be exact against the Trump
organization and then this dumb [__]
manga cultist tells me tells me that I
can't oh you can't equate that you have
to separate Donald Trump the man and
Donald Trump the business person that's
what he said in this space he kept
saying it over and over and over it's
the dumbest [__] argument I've ever
heard in my life because if I if me if
we have to separate Donald Trump the
businessman and Donald Trump the person
then you [__] manga cultist you have
to separate Donald Trump the man and
Donald Trump the former president of the
United States
and that is exactly how it should be
that is exactly how it should be
so if that's what we must do Maga
and again they're losing the plot line
I've told you this time and time again
it's slipping out from underneath them
they can't they can't figure out what
exactly they want the narrative to be
and the reason why is because Donald
Trump keeps yelling and screaming for
Mar-A-Lago keeps yelling and screaming
from fraud social saying [__] like
horsey face horsey face it horsey face
this horsey face I never [__] her who
cares if you [__] her or not
apparently the only person who cares if
you've [__] her or not is you that is
it no one else gives a [__] if you even
even the people who claim to be [__]
white Christian nationalists and the
moral majority in this country don't
give a [__] that you screwed some porn
star and committed adultery against your
wife who was pregnant they don't give a
[__] even the people who you would think
would [__] give a [__] you know all
the people who were appalled who were
appalled and still hate Bill Clinton
because Monica Lewinsky gave him [__]
head
that those same [__] are not
concerned not concerned at all in the
least
that Donald Trump committed adultery not
at all that no one gives a [__] no one
cares but him
that he that he may or may not have had
sex with Stormy Daniels
why the why the [__] does anyone think
this has to do with the [__] check
that was written to Stormy Daniels or
the idea of the of the NDA that's what
they keep saying the NDA oh well he had
98 it was it was a it was an agreement
who gives a [__] rat's ass I'm
talking about the crime that happened
after the fact after they had done
whatever they did
after the fact that he wanted to pay her
a hush money payment
I'm not even saying that the hush money
payment should be illegal [__] I'm not
even saying it should be illegal to pay
someone for a sexual act that's right I
don't give a [__]
I don't care if I think prostitution
should be legal exp in the in the uh in
the universe of consent of course
but prostitution should be absolutely
ill be legal
sex work is work and we should protect
these people who want to do that
who I don't give a [__] about the hush
money payment
I don't care
if he had sex with her or didn't and he
wanted to cover it up because he was
running for president that doesn't
bother me at all
what does bother me is when Maga says oh
you're making this political you're
making this political it's all polit
yeah it's [__] political
he paid her to not say what they did in
a bedroom somewhere while he was married
to Melania Trump and she was pregnant
with Baron so he could run in a
presidential political campaign
and when he was the president of the
United States he made sure it looks like
to commit fraud to make sure
that he paid back Michael Cohen
and mind you
when they did look into his business
records in Trump org and these 17 counts
of tax fraud and Alan weisselberg I'm
sure that Stormy Daniels payment
was one of the [__] frauds that they
were looking at
my guess is just my guess this is just
my guess that Donald Trump does what he
always does and he was obstructing that
investigation into that payment
witness tampering much I don't know who
knows who the [__] I mean this guy
constantly lies to not only his
supporters which is all the time he lie
tries to lie to us he doesn't get away
with that [__] because we're smarter
than that [__] than these [__]
moglodytes who believe everything this
[__] buffoon says
but he lies to his attorneys too who are
defending him we know this
we know this so why can't you see that
maybe just maybe oh my God just maybe
that Alan Bragg in the Manhattan da and
the grand jury have evidence
that is irrefutable that's not that's
not good and honestly I think this is
what it is and the reason why is because
my guess is that Donald Trump and his
legal team know exactly what the charges
are going to be
exactly
they know exactly what the charges are
going to be and if they really were just
flimsy ass charges because that's what
everyone keeps saying it's all this case
is flimsy if it's so flimsy why doesn't
he say that
why doesn't he attack that point
because he can't
just like he can't attack this crime
fraud exclusion that Jack Smith got him
on oh boy yeah let me tell you something
holy [__]
oh
rap bro
oh no
the appeals court
um is rushing through
this appeal my guess is here's my guess
and again it's just based off the
evidence that I have from Donald Trump
right and and basically what he has said
and more importantly what he has
projected here
my guess is that the information that
the crime fraud exclusion is Donald
Trump has misled his attorneys to lead
them believe that he has turned
everything over that there's nothing
else that he has and there is [__] that
he has and it is a national security
interest
and that's probably why Jack Smith in
the Department of Justice is moving so
fast on this crime fraud exception is
because that attorney knows that [__]
and he can't protect Donald Trump
anymore because the attorney is now
trying to obstruct Justice by by lying
to the doj when the attorney knows that
Donald Trump has National Security
secrets
I don't know if you're a hate Watcher
out there right if you're a Maga and you
hate watch this show Welcome by the way
just first off welcome to Welcome to the
universe of Truth okay
welcome to the universe of Truth
and how I'm gonna lay it on you [__]
but here's the thing
um in the crime fraud exception it is
very rare very rare that a judge
anywhere will grant this accession
unless there is very very substantial
evidence of that crime fraud exception
now
in this case where they're trying to
hurry it through my guess is is that
there is National Security interest at
risk here Jack Smith knows it Department
of Justice knows it
and the court knows it
and they keep saying they want documents
they want information they want
documents
well what better than the court to order
that they would hand the [__] over that
he's lying about and the attorney was
lying about and the attorney knew he was
lying about hmm I don't know these are
just speculations it's just all
conspiracy theory
but am I throwing a rock that doesn't
sound like it's gonna land
no absolutely not why else would they be
rushing
everyone keeps saying oh they're rushing
because Donald Trump's like to likes to
obstruct really 12 [__] hours is all
they're giving 12.
come on that's all nonsense that's all
nonsense they would do this in days or
two days or 24 hours or at least at
least at least
at least give the public some kind of
sense they're moving fast
because there's something at stake here
and they found something
Jesus Christ last week we found out that
the crime fraud exception was being
considered and then we found out that
Jack Smith was going to subpoena [__]
staff members from Mar-A-Lago
that are in and around the vicinity
where these conversations or this stuff
was being hidden whatever the [__] he's
lying about because he's lying about
something that is I mean always
I mean he's always [__] lying about
something
let's not kid ourselves here
but there's something to rush there's
something to rush here so what is it
what is there to rush and it doesn't
look like on the reporting that the
grand jury in Manhattan aren't going to
meet today
um
who knows yesterday there was bomb
threats I don't know where Marjorie
Taylor green was why those phone calls
were being made but apparently there was
what I'm not I'm not saying that she had
anything to do with it all I'm saying is
I kind of want to know where she was
when the phone calls are being made I
don't
if you can prove that she was you know
somewhere else besides on the phone I I
would like to see the evidence
I don't know what to tell you
she did this to herself
um so I want to know where Margie Taylor
green was when these bomb threats were
being called in I'd like to know I think
America would like to know that as well
um but apparently bomb threats were
called in yesterday as the judge gaveled
in for the civil case that Tish James
the New York attorney general has
against the Trump org where she's going
to cut them down like a fresh cut tree
he's she's totally gonna smash up their
money laundering machine with a hammer
so now
again this gets worse for Donald Trump
and worse and worse and worse um it
looks like the sdny
has moved further into their case of uh
get money laundering of eight million
dollars from the Caribbean of Russians
money into Trump media which was his
next money laundering scheme uh when the
Trump organization when dish James Burns
that [__] down and pisses on the
ashes Trump media was supposed to be the
next money laundering machine it doesn't
look like that Speck
is gonna speckle if you know what I'm
talking about if you know what I'm
saying you smell what I'm stepping in oh
it's crime everywhere hey you know what
hey Grandpa stop criming that'll help
that'll [__] help okay just stop
criming like it would be good if you
today if you just stop doing crime
I would that would help everything out
everything would be okay now the other
[__] um yesterday in this uh space
that we had the other argument that they
were making is that he's running for
president of the United States I mean he
said as much but what ballot is he on
When someone tells you that [__] in a
thread or or they're [__] commented
to you have them [__] point out what
petition that he has in his hand to go
on what ballot ask them they don't know
how this process works what do they
think he just says I'm running for
president and they put his name on a
ballot somewhere they're already
printing them off you're a bunch of dumb
[__] man you this this is the
problem that we have in the United
States of America even educated people
people who we think should be you know
have a [__] couple bring cells to rub
together to understand how our system of
government works and doesn't even
understand there's not an election
we are not we are not in an election
cycle there is not an election he sings
running for president and I mean there's
a [__] election I hey I could say I'm
running for president what if I went and
[__] robbed a bank and when the cops
came and picked me up I said whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa officers you can't arrest
me I just made a video on the internet
the other day that might have said that
I'm running for president so I'm immune
you can't arrest me you can't charge me
with a crime ha ha ha na na boo boo
stick your head in doo-doo these are the
arguments that they're making it's
really [__] done really [__]
stupid he's not on a ballot now I've
said before this is his strategy his
strategy is to get on balance to win
primaries to tell these judges which
will work I'm telling you it's going to
piss you off but it's gonna work it's
gonna work this strategy of election is
going to work not not working now to not
get indicted they don't give a [__] if
he's running if he says if he says he's
running for president they don't give a
[__]
because no judge is gonna buy that he's
in an election because he's not on a
ballot he doesn't have petitions for a
ballot because there are no petitions
for any ballots anywhere in any states
show them to me
and then and then we'll talk okay
and then we'll go for that
so that's that's the other stupid
argument
but there's a lot of dumb arguments out
there with Maga oh a lot and we're going
to show a couple here from Donald Trump
Jr oh my God this [__] guy I also I
also have a tape from yesterday from the
same space Oh you're not gonna believe
this you're not gonna believe this [__]
this is [__] this is crazy wild [__]
yesterday I was in the space in Twitter
space and um I I don't remember all who
was in there why I was in there but but
I had the I I chimed in a couple times
to push back on these [__] stupid
narratives and these stupid arguments
that make no sense from Maga they just
don't make any sense you start to think
about them I don't know with ration
rational thought logic it just they they
Melt Away in a minute
but later on in the in the evening Lev
Parnes I don't know if you know who lead
Barnes is lead Barnes went to prison for
Rudy Giuliani you remember this guy
he helped in the Ukrainian deal to try
to get uh president zielinski to
investigate Joe Biden they were using uh
funding and a meeting with the president
United States Donald Trump at the time
as a little as a little nugget to
convince him to open up a criminal
investigation into Joe and Hunter Biden
you remember this you remember this
he was impeached for it
yeah that was that was the Republicans
opportunity to bounce this son of a
[__] but they didn't take it Le partnes
went to prison for that let Parnes is
out now on house arrest and let Parnes
has been showing up in these Twitter
spaces oh my God last night I'm gonna
show you the [__] I'm gonna show you
the tape it's gonna be audio because
that's all Twitter spaces is his audio
but it's on video but I'm gonna show it
to you to you today where let Barnes let
Barnes claims
that that they drugged Hunter Biden and
Kazakhstan they drugged him and and and
gave him and bought him hookers
and they took his [__] laptop and
copied the hard drive and then took it
to the the repair shop in Delaware
that is what led Parnes is claiming now
I don't I don't I I don't know that
anyone is refuting this or has any other
evidence for or against it but let
Barnes says he has he has evidence of
this and that's what happened
holy actual [__]
and they did all this to get it into
that repair lab shops that repair shop
to get the laptop in the hands of Rudy
Giuliani and I'm gonna show you what he
says now again I I the only thing I can
tell you is that Leb Barnes was
definitely a part of Rudy's Universe
while the laptop [__] was happening in
2018 and 2019 especially and into 2020.
but in this Twitter space let parnis
says
that Hunter Biden
was drugged
and was given hookers to distract him so
they could copy his laptop hard drive
I'm not [__] you that's what he says
I I again that's the news I I he says he
has evidence of this and and I listened
to the space last night a little bit
with les in it
right I I listened to it and um the
problem that the space had is because
the night before they were trying to
really make Lev look like an idiot like
he didn't know what he was talking about
and then last night they tried to do the
same thing but they brought someone in
who is a who is a a Rudy Confidant who
actually backs up Life's story in the
space
like backs his story up in the space
which only gives more credential
to what it Lev is saying about the
hunter Biden laptop now we all know that
the hunter Biden lamp dap is all
[__] it's all [__] and the more
than likely because what Partners also
claims that all this evidence that he
has the proper authorities have this
evidence which means more than likely
Leb Parnes gave this information to get
the plea deal that he took that he went
to prison to some degree and we didn't
go to trial with this
that's why we may have not have seen
this evidence and this may be the other
reason why Maga is so frustrated that
Hunter Biden isn't [__] prosecuted
for the laptop because the authorities
know that it's not real they know that
it's not real they know that it's all
[__] I mean yeah the pictures of him
having sex with hookers and doing drugs
that may be real but who who the [__]
cares if Hunter Biden the son of the
president United States who is not at
all tied to our government Hunter Biden
is not a is not
is not an officer of our government in
any shape or form who gives a [__] I
mean yeah the guy's got a drug problem
he likes to have sex with prostitutes
but again I actually don't believe that
any of that should be illegal
I actually believe that a drug habit
should be treated as a health care issue
not as a crime and if you want to have
consensual sex with someone and they
want you to pay them and you pay them I
don't think that should be a crime
either but whatever that's my opinion
that's not the [__] law
so if the only crime that they have the
only crime that they have on on Hunter
Biden
is that he did some blow and [__] some
hookers good luck good luck to you
Donald Trump Jr I'd love to see what's
on Donald Trump Jr's laptop I'd love to
see what is in on the thumb drive that
is in Jared kushner's pocket when he
went over to the World Cup I don't know
it looked like he could I mean I don't
know he could have had a thumb drive in
his pocket how am I supposed to know did
someone search him did someone see did
he hand something to Elon when they were
standing there talking I don't know do
you know
it's these are these are these are
questions that we must ask how do we
know how do we know that Jared Kushner
didn't take a thumb drive from Donald
Trump and use it as payment to the
Saudis how do we know that Elon Musk
wasn't told what to do with the Twitter
files by Jared Kushner at the World Cup
how do we know is are we supposed to
believe
oh [__] I love I love how Tucker Carlson
does that don't you I love Ellie gas
lights I love that gas lights I love any
questions I love how he destroys our
democracy with the stupid [__]
thinking right well hey Tucker hey
Tucker if you're gonna say it just say
it you hate this country you hate
democracy and you hate Liberty you love
fascism just say it just [__] say it
already you goddamn Nazi oh man
boom I'm on fire today today's Wednesday
guess what we got a special guest today
Dr Rachel bidikoffer is going to join us
at the top of the hour so you're going
to want to stay tuned the entire show
today and anyways you're going to want
to stay tuned for until the very end why
wouldn't you I'm going to show you this
video of lead Parnes
um I know I know Gabe Sanchez is
probably excited about watching this
video here of web Partners maybe we'll
do that when we come back from the break
but first off I want to I want to do a
few pieces of business here for the best
audience in the world we got we had a
ton of new subscribers yesterday here on
the YouTube channel we had a huge
audience we had a huge audience right
now and if you [__] are not
hitting the Subscribe button you're
doing it wrong it's free it doesn't cost
you a single goddamn nickel to subscribe
here to the Tony Michaels podcast on
YouTube You're Gonna Wanna Do it okay
now if you have a Twitter account go
follow us at Tony Michaels POD at the
Tony Michaels and that I am Gabe Sanchez
you're going to want to follow this
there and the reason why is because we
hop in and out of this space and
apparently tonight Leb Parnes is
supposed to come back that's what he
said he said he would come back they
were trying to get Rudy in Rudy Giuliani
in the space with lead partners that
ain't gonna [__] happen then he gonna
[__] name but what explain that when
we get to that download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
here
on Apple Spotify Google hell go download
it on all of them it's free it's free 99
doesn't cost you a single nickel to go
download it on every single one if
you're on Facebook or have a Facebook
account
make sure you're following me there at
the Tony Michaels if you're on Midas
Touch Facebook page I don't know if you
noticed but at the top I put my link
right there for you to go follow just
click it and go okay follow that's all
you got to do uh make sure you follow
follow And subscribe to the up wires
YouTube channel as well
um you know we were over there during
the band we were still um streaming over
there so go follow the up wire go to the
upwire.com or just search the up wire on
YouTube and also follow us on Twitch
don't forget to download the Twitch app
and link your s your Amazon Prime
account did you know if you have an
Amazon Prime account you can give me a
couple dollars of Jeff bezos's money and
it doesn't cost you a single nickel all
you got to do is link your Amazon Prime
account to Twitch account and you get
one free subscription over on Twitch you
give your favorites twitch streamer
which should be me obviously
I mean you're watching the show right
now aren't you go over link those
accounts give us your one free
subscription and it doesn't cost you a
single nickel to give us monetary
support here at the Tony Michaels
podcast you are the best goddamn
audience in the world and I say world
because there are people right now
listening this that are all around the
world shout out in the chat to everyone
that is international that listens to
this show and the Americans and the
people in this country who are listening
to this show you are in the right spot
if you're looking for the national
narrative and National messaging to kick
Trump's ass in 2024. it's right here and
let me tell you something we're not
going to let up not at all we're going
to get to these videos as soon as the
break's over and Dr Rachel bidikoffer at
the top of the hour don't go anywhere
you're not going to want to miss it
stick around we'll be right back right
after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment we're
[Music]
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
Hump Day you gotta take back a Rachel
bit of golfer at the top of the hour
stay tuned uh to see Dr Rachel
bittickoffer we're going to talk about
how manga has lost the plot line and
that all they can talk about is Donald
Trump's crime
that's all they can talk about
have you noticed they haven't said
anything about Chinese spy balloons or
inflation or gas stoves gas prices they
lost the [__] plot folks
all they can talk about is all the crime
Donald Trump is committing they're like
oh well he's uh the hush money porn star
and the fraud and the the tax fraud of
trump Oregon he he's not guilty of of
obstruction of the documents and he
didn't inside a riot they're really
losing the plot line that's all they can
talk about is the crime that Donald
Trump is committing and whining about it
it's the cope Brigade
I mean full-on cope Brigade that's what
you should call them that's what I
called him yesterday coat Burger Coke
Jesus cope Brigade it's hard to say cope
Brigade
and spell it out on Twitter don't say it
out loud who gives a [__]
oh Bailey says they're stepping in their
own [__] yeah well I like to say it's
the [__] sandwich eating the [__]
sandwich that's what's happening here
they made their [__] sandwich and now
they're eating it oh it tastes so good
to them too and I love honestly I love
watching them eat this [__] sandwich
it's hilarious it's hilarious and you
guys should come check out these spaces
because at first it seems like oh my God
I can't stand it because these people
are so out of their [__] minds and
all the crazy [__] they're saying in
this space
really if you get just one or two people
in there like me or Ed or Gabe or Tara
and you get just one or two people in
there with half a [__] brain and a
few brain cells still left rolling
around in our skull and you put I don't
know rational thought and logic to the
to the issue at hand
it really [__] makes them look stupid
I mean bad and they get [__] pissed I
mean they get pissed Sebastian Gorka he
is [__] he hates me in game he
[__] hates us Tom Fenton [__]
hates us they [__] hate us every time
I say something or every time Gabe says
something in this space and Seb is in
there he's like you [__]
I mean he just he just can't stop he
can't stop but to be triggered by
anything we're saying it's [__]
hilarious [__] hilarious and I know I
know Seb may not have known who we were
at first like I get it I I get it
there's a line of Talking Heads out
there I understand you know right now
we're kind of a small show maybe
um we're we're on the Midas touch
Network so I think that's kind of how he
took notice right we're on WE stream to
the minus touch Facebook page so maybe
that's how he took notice of me and Gabe
uh Gabe puts what was that over on the
Midas touch networks channel so you know
when he figured that out he actually
figured out that whoa
these might these two might be someone I
need to be triggered by
and I'll let me tell you never fails he
never disappoints and I don't think we
disappoint Seb either I don't think we
disappoint Seb now a lot of people don't
like the heat that I bring in the room
because I don't I don't I'm not [__]
calm in the room right like I I'm not
I'm not who I am here and then I'm
someone different in the room this is
[__] me this is [__] me in the
room I don't give two shits and I don't
I could care less if Seb Gorka gets his
panties in a wad I don't give a [__]
coat [__] and so I gotta say cope with
it I don't know what what do you want
from me I'm just telling you the [__]
truth the way that the American people
see it well what do you want me for what
do you want for me Seb I know Gabe feels
the same way and again and it feels like
to me that Seb said thinks I'm I'm a
joke Gabe but it really feels like to me
he's got something personal with you
like there's I I don't I don't know yeah
I don't it's it's uh it's it's one of
those things where like again I didn't
I've never interacted with Seb on
Twitter I've never tweeted about him
like you could go through my history
uh I mean obviously recently well I've
always thought he was a joke really
right yeah yeah no no 100 but what I
will say is like I never directly
tweeted at him never tagged him never
made a video mocking him but now I
definitely will uh I've never done any
meme or photoshop of him I've never done
anything that would say oh yeah I did
attack him attack him uh on Twitter
right you want to explain to Eric yeah
you want to explain Eric who is Seb yeah
Seb Gorka is uh he
he's a nobody but he did work he's like
I don't know he's definitely British uh
Hungarian I think the thing is I think
he was on the truck painted 2016 and
then he entered the white house but he
was such a joke that he could he took
the role as a as an advisor right and
then yeah he was uh you know what what
he was probably he was [__] pass a
background check right well what he was
trying to argue uh you two yeah two days
ago in the spaces that he had signed an
NDA he was trying to push the idea like
oh ndas I signed ndas
I wonder if that's the same NDA that
Jessica Denton um
because he said it's the campaign's uh
NDA so that might be the same India it
might be the same we should we should uh
you know what that now that I think
about that we should try to get Jess
gone maybe uh and ask her about that uh
if it's the same one I don't know I'm
just so what he did I mean if like if I
were to quickly summarize what he did it
was nothing uh but during that he did I
know he gave interviews he yells and
screams really loud I mean yeah yeah
he's like yeah
he holds guns and he puts uh pictures of
him and guns on Instagram he does that
it's the the thing is like he's this
right-wing Fringe character who can't
answer I mean again I asked him on
Tuesday or on Monday I said did Donald
Trump lie about the 2020 election he
could not answer it he got silent he got
silent he rerouted and was like what
about this and I was like shut the [__]
up man you and everyone else in here
keeps pushing this idea that their
election was was stolen that it was some
plot by the never trumpers and the
Democrats to come against Trump no he
just [__] lost and you guys can't do
simple math and accept the facts
that he's a loser but Seb Gorka worked
for Trump as an advisor in 2017 I want
to say uh yeah 20 August 2017 oh sorry
January 27 right 2017 to August end of
August and then they bounced him out of
the White House right and so I wonder
why that too much he defended the
administration's positions on National
Security and foreign policy AKA he was
the pro-muslim band like those are the
types of stuff that he did right right
so he said was it he hates Muslims dude
he's the biggest bigot he's a he's a big
you know break the news breaking news
Gabe I've got a uh this apparently Uh Oh
I thought this was Sebastian I thought
this was said well it's close enough
let's take a listen to what what the
cope Brigade is doing out in Arizona
Let's listen uh just left we have more
people on the way there's a news report
that
um I guess they're telling the cops to
suit up that they intend on arresting
Trump today that's what I think I heard
you guys check that on the media so get
your asses out here we're just making
lunch
if it rains it rains uh Crystal just
left well I got confused I thought it
was said but it's just said supporters
It's just sad but supportive now I
called this the cope Brigade yesterday
apparently this was out in Arizona you
see this guy cooking it looks like
garlic bread over a torch and then he
this guy's using they're [__] using
the same camping gas gear that you would
well when you're out at in the woods
right like yeah but God come on man
there's the thing
everyone every all Americans know how to
[__] tailgate to some degree right
this is all for a show you bring a
[__] barbecue grill you [__] turds
a barbecue girl in a goddamn cooler I
think Linda said Alinda said on and
commented on this um that when I tweeted
uh maybe I can find it here she's
I think she said are they [__] yeah
are they [__] it well she's a little
more uh has a little more than me she
says do they poop in the same cans they
eat out of I mean you know they're
camping so maybe they're [__] in
them
you know all I know is that the
Democrats those libs are coming after
the woke washing machines
dishwashers and your toilets so you know
that they're like to to push the push
the envelope and say you can't take my
my right as an American to [__]
now it's anywhere I want
so I'm sure that they are they're
[__] inside the you know like they
they say don't [__] when you eat well
they will take away my gas stoves and my
[__] buckets I see what you livetards
are doing okay so here is uh because
this this is this is [__] wild [__]
man
um because in this room and you see here
this is a screenshot here and there is
Seb or Sebastian Gorka there yeah and
Lead Parnes is this from yesterday or
the day before
um well this is
um this is from yesterday oh this is
from Monday then is it this is yeah
because this is this is where he broke
down the the laptop and said that there
was no actual investigation into Hunter
Biden no this is where he says Hunter
Biden was drugged right right yeah this
is from Monday Monday oh okay this is
Monday okay so so let's let's listen to
this someone posted this um I want to
play this now it's three minutes long
I'm not gonna play the whole thing he
says it at the end here so let's um
probably about
the last minute here now let's listen to
what Leb Partners has to say about
Hunter Biden and how they got the laptop
so it's incriminating on us but again I
don't know I didn't see the stuff on
there that was incriminating or because
there was something to it she's talking
about the laptop
was
well we were told that there was stuff
incriminating on us but again I don't
know I didn't see the stuff that was on
it how would you know that this
incriminating stuff on this laptop I
could only go from what we were told by
the Russian NASA which I can't divulge
his name as of yet but the proper
authorities know his name
so I just want to get this right so
you're saying the laptop that was in
that shop in the United States
some Russian asset was aware that that
shocked that Hunter Biden gone to the
shop and given the laptop no no that's
not what I'm saying what I'm saying was
that we were told in 2019 in June at a
meeting in chapriani's the hunter Biden
was fed drugs given prostitutes in
Kazakhstan while he was there supposedly
to meet a minister in Kazakhstan and
they would his computer was taken to use
this compromise against him now I don't
know by the FSB and by zlichevski his
boss barisma those were the two
different uh entities that had that hard
drive now I don't know what was on that
hard drive I don't know what was planted
or not planted on that hard drive I
can't say I don't know if that's the
real hard drive but I know for a fact
that Giuliani knew and Trump know about
that hard drive way before it was found
in Delaware so there you have it and
what he's claiming there if you missed
it is that Hunter Biden was drugged in
Kazakhstan
um and get fed drugs and who hookers
which again it's probably not hard to
convince Hunter Biden to take drugs and
and have sex with hookers to distract
him a little bit to take his laptop and
copy it but that is what he was told how
they obtained the hard drive now rather
that's true or not let Partners is
saying I don't I have no idea but that's
what they're telling me how they
obtained it now he's also what he's also
claiming is that Hunter Biden didn't
take his laptop to that repair shop he
didn't take it there what he's saying is
that the the hard drive was copied
in Kazakhstan and then taken to Delaware
now once it re once it came to the
repair shop in Delaware that's when Rudy
Giuliani worked with the authorities to
get it released to him right okay from
that repair shop which if you do I mean
if you use deductive reasoning here you
can like be like okay so what makes more
sense what makes more sense that Hunter
Biden took his laptop to some some
strange repair shop to a blind guy and
and this guy found something on his
laptop and then gave it to Rudy Giuliani
or does it make more sense what Lev is
saying does it make more sense that they
wanted his laptop and they wanted to
plant [__] on his laptop possibly or get
the [__] off his laptop so they went and
stole it overseas planted it in a repair
shop in Delaware knowing that it was
going to be there how did Rudy know it
was at the repair shop how did he know
it's that is the biggest question there
where you have to ask yourself I mean if
you actually have
a working brain you have to ask yourself
how would Rudy know to go to that
specific
Delaware uh computer shop repair shop
how would the Blind repair shop owner
know
that it was actually Hunter Biden you
know Amanda the shop owner could not
identify the guy who dropped it off
right so it really comes to the point of
like the only thing they have to work
off is a signature on the piece of paper
which for anyone could be forged could
be a stamp could be whatever
but you have to ask yourself if Rudy
Giuliani and Donald Trump and others
knew in June of 2019
and the laptop wasn't recovered until
October of 2020 which is be a month
before the election right the October
surprise I mean no one should no one
should be surprised when something comes
up in October right someone's been
waiting on it you need enough time to
get it before the election to make an
impact and this is one of those things
so the idea that this went to a Delaware
repair shop by Hunter Biden and he
forgot that he dropped it off and never
picked it up then the repair shop owner
was like oh he never picked it up so now
I'm gonna look in here and I know
exactly who to give it to the very
person who knew there was a hard drive
or a laptop that consisted of these
images from Hunter Biden I should
contact him directly the thing it just
there's there's no such thing as
coincidence okay it feels like it feels
like to me that that
um Trump's team including Rudy Giuliani
wanted to use Hunter Biden's laptop as a
way to get at Joe Biden yeah and they
knew they couldn't just steal
right they knew they couldn't just steal
it so what they had to do was figure out
a way to get it in their hands right and
they had to get it in their hands with
compromising information it's almost
like it's almost like they they set it
up and maybe just maybe what Lev Barnes
is saying is the truth about how they
set it up here's another claim that Lev
makes because he keeps talking about a
Russian asset and I want everyone to
understand
um I actually I don't know because he
never I don't know did he ever really
say because I've tried to watch the
space win letters in there did he ever
really say is the is the Russian asset a
Russian national are they an American
does he say who they are he doesn't say
that he just says there's a Russian
asset I can't say like he said in one
clip he's like I can't divulge who they
are right now right but they're a
Russian ass it feels like it feels like
what he's saying and again this is just
my feeling my belief right right I have
no opinion on this because I don't have
any facts other than what Lev is saying
it feels like to me I believe that that
we we would know who it is yeah that
that's what it feels when he keeps
saying it it feels like I believe that
we would know now not not the American
people as a whole but people who have
been following this story would know who
it is because they would be close to
Rudy because here's this um now this was
from last night the other one I I
misspoke on Twitter earlier
um the the clip I just played was from
the night before but this was from last
night uh I believe no no no same this
one this this is yeah because this is
the one with Millie in it this is the
one that's no no no Millie was in on
Monday night as well oh okay okay and
Bernard this guy this is okay for quick
because the reason I know this is
because there's this Bernard guy here in
the middle that's to the right okay
Bernard right here and is some crazy
Mega Trumper who ran for office and
didn't win he said he was an Olympian he
he went on tangent he said the election
was stolen because he didn't win right
he was like a patterns
he tried to come up with some like
analogy of Olympians uh it's very easy
for Olympians to cheat by taking drugs
and stuff and in Lev I don't know if he
intentionally said it this way or if he
just misheard but he's like I'm sorry
that you feel like you have to win as an
athlete to take drugs so that says more
about you than it says about me yeah but
this is from the same night this is okay
so this is from okay now in this clip
because it's only under a minute
um listen to what Leb partnes says about
the Russian accent and Rudy Giuliani
listen
disagree with you that what you've seen
because I haven't seen it and I'm not
going to debate that but what I'm saying
to you is you've seen that information
only after it came out giuliani's hands
you didn't see that directly right out
of the shop or or even on the computer
all that information that's being
disseminated is being disseminated after
Giuliani took that computer and hard
drive away from that shop he was the
first person to get it so you make up
your own mind Giuliani is the same guy
that went and tried to
go to Georgia and all these other states
by saying that there is no uh that the
election was stolen I was with Giuliani
when he and Saul looked him in the eye
and knew when he forced certain
prosecutors when they called him up and
said we don't have the evidence and he
told him to go find it
okay so so that didn't I thought I was
going to talk about the Russian asset
part no no that was that's a different I
don't know if anyone has the recording
from last night there's hours there's
hours there's Hours of Le Barnes I mean
at one point when I was like I had
meetings yesterday and I was working I
was Tony was on I didn't I didn't speak
yesterday I was just in there listening
uh but the [__] that I heard yesterday
and also the fact of which at the very
end of the call or the very end of the
space yesterday yeah because I listened
to the end when he was like right so at
the very end for people who weren't
there for the full thing or at least
wasn't there for the end what happened
was
this girl Millie that Tony referenced
earlier there's this girl Millie and
this other girl or woman Tori and Tori
is this person that they refer to as
Chaos Agent or chaos something like that
whatever anyway
she had made claims they both had made
claims but this chaos woman had made
claims as a journalist
the night that we just played is her
account Anonymous on Twitter is that why
they can't say who she is or what yeah
but somebody I wasn't in there somebody
divulged her name as Tori last night and
then it was Mike yeah it was it was the
guy they brought in to try to to try to
prove Lev was wrong and and the mic guy
like said yeah that makes sense he he
agreed with everything Lev said he
backed up Lev's story and Millie I mean
was standing in a bucket of [__] at that
point so basically what happened was
they they bring Levin he's like look I'm
not even supposed to talk today but I
came in to debunk a lot of what was said
what I was hearing I'm supposed to come
on either maybe today or sometime later
this week so Lev comes on he goes look
you guys are saying this stuff I'll
answer the questions again whatever you
have to say let me just point this out
the night before chaos was saying things
like you were evicted from a trump condo
10 years ago your son Aaron worked for
Mike Pence or tried to work for Mike
Pence you who were you went to Spain to
go meet this FBI agent who was bad all
of this stuff right so then Millie who
brought who's the connection that
brought in Rudy Giuliani on Monday right
so Rudy came in for like 15 minutes so
that's how Rudy got in the room and she
kind of told me tell him who Millie is
tell him who Millie is because that's
important that's important right so
Millie is a is a q an honor who I didn't
know this until I I mean you know that's
that's insulting to Q Anon I mean
come on she she's a Mike Lindell my
pillow Nazi she's on Frank's Beach but
then it turns out we found out last
night uh that she stole a hundred and
seventy thousand dollars worth of items
from her mother right wasn't that oh God
damn well it was a lot of money yeah and
then and then even though she stole
those things like robbed her mother then
she tried to raise money fundraise money
for her legal defense she did I think
not only did she steal from her mother
but then she was like Hey guys look give
me the money to defend my I need money
to to for my legal defense because I I
robbed my own mother
and then
that like that that is who she that is
magination baby crazy it's crazy Honor
on her Twitter page did you go look at
her Twitter page it says reporter
investigative journalist I'm like get
the [__] out of here our independent
journalism
I'm sorry I I I misspoke she raised a
hundred and seventy thousand dollars for
her legal fund after she stole my
favorite she robbed her own mother
needed to raise money because she said
it's full of deep state conspiracy so
this is the person who got Rudy Giuliani
in the space right the the actual answer
is the simplest answer which she robbed
her mother and then gripped at 170 000
to make sure that she wasn't or that she
had enough to actually fight it the best
part last night was when she gets this
mic guy who apparently met Rudy Giuliani
in Spain or no was it in Spain or was it
yeah so so what happened well Madrid is
in space sorry I I can't get the there
there's a 100 different places they win
around is for everyone who doesn't know
Millie is the connection point between
any anyone else and Rudy right now right
so if Rudy came into the space it was
because Millie reached out to Rudy Rudy
came into the space on Monday and then
what happened last night is there were
all these claims right and Lev was like
look I'm telling you the truth you can
say these things and I'm going to debunk
them so what what ends up happening is
Millie says hey I've got this guy Mike
Mike what you're saying right he's going
to debunk what you're saying and he is a
client of Rudy Giuliani so she reaches
out to him we're waiting he comes into
the call and then it becomes this moment
of like Lev says let's just get this
right off the bat right let's start to
ask you a question Matt have we ever met
have I ever spoken to have you ever
talked on the phone have you ever done
anything and he's like no we have this
is the first time we've ever met he goes
great okay so Millie and Chaos that is
uh your conspiracy number one debunked
we've never met we've never spoken and
then this other this other moment of
because they had Mike tell the story
right they hadn't tell the story about
Spain what he said was Giuliani was
going to Spain and coincidentally
he also Mike knew an FBI agent that he
had to speak to about some case he was
working on right in Spain and she told
Giuliani to reach out to him and he's
like hey you're going to Spain yeah
you're going to Spain this is great you
can meet this FBI agent while you're
there you're what you know one of the
best parts of the whole story the one of
the best parts of the whole [__]
story is this that Rudy Giuliani was
with let Parnes and his security guard
right because Rudy Giuliani tries to
travel with the security guard right
right and they were in a [__] Palace
okay well let me let me repeat it let me
repeat it for you Maga idiots out there
who think that we're the elitist that
Liberals are the Elite
Rudy Giuliani Went to went to Madrid
Spain and stayed in a palace are you
catching that a palace that's where he
was staying while he was he was he was
planning to make sure that Donald Trump
would have a way to win because they
were going to get the president of
Ukraine to [__] have some fake fake
ass investigation into Joe Biden he was
in a let me say it again let me let me
not a farmhouse not a cabin yeah a
palace yeah that and and then 100
million I think and then then it was so
funny because all the men in the river
was it right they they're like he's like
I don't know 40 rooms right he's like
it's [__] huge there's like 300 acres
it's like two two 200 miles from any
civilization like or two hours from any
civilization he's like there's no way
Rudy could get in or out without a car
there's no way that anyone could have
come on or on a property without people
knowing yeah he's like it's a palace
it's a [__] Palace it's in the middle
of a property surrounded by land and
just right Wilderness it's a palace so
so then this Millie girl was like whoa
when this girl chaos was like oh whoa
whoa what we have here is a conflict of
narrative yeah we have a conflict of
which is like so ridiculous you have one
guy who's like look I'm telling you this
you made these claims I'm debunking them
and the person that you brought up as
your witness to agree with it wrong
agreed and also said well that's right
now oh yeah right well but but he's
saying yeah that's how that's how it
happened that's how it happened right on
my end so then you know meanwhile Tony
and I are talking in the background uh
you know via text and we're like dude
the only person who can answer this
question or who rather it's Rudy is yeah
is Rudy which I I want Rudy come on Rudy
I was like let's get
Rudy I wanted Rudy the problem here is
because this this girl chaos was like no
what I said was totally true and so
really what we have here is a conflict
of narrative which again that's not a
thing
narrative if you guys really want the
answer the only way we could have an
actual conversation Rudy is with Rudy
you've got Lev on one side who says he
was there with Rudy and Rudy says well
obviously he went to Spain but now we
have to understand exactly where the
narrative splits off between Rudy saying
he met and he had this and found this
and he did this versus left saying I was
with Rudy the whole time he may have had
a conversation that I don't know about
but we were in this place the whole time
and we had security which then he goes
oh yeah Sal he said he goes oh did you
to this mic guy who was like supposed to
obviously debunk what Lev said he goes
uh oh you talk about cell security and
Mike was like yeah yeah Sal which they
both again they're they're they are
corroborating each other's story here
which is they went to Spain
they were all Rudy was already going to
Spain with or to to meet uh Lev parnis
and Mike in this conversation was like
yeah well he was already going there so
I was gonna have him meet this FBI agent
which is if the guy knew the FBI agent
was in Spain and was like this guy needs
to help me on this case it totally
debunks this style or this this this
narrative that uh it was a it was a
corrupt FBI agent that was working with
Lev parnis and Lev parnis was an FBI
informant right so it's just this idea
that the only way that we can have the
actual answer to this debate this
question is to bring Rudy in but we know
that Rudy Giuliani will not come into
this space if Lev parnis is also in this
space well and I want to point out
Fatima here's asked the question why the
hell are they still free and I want I
want to point out to what Lev said and
how he was told because lab was not that
he does not claim he was there when
Hunter Biden's laptop was stolen yeah he
does not he does not claim he was there
he was he he's claims he's being told
that's how they got access to it is they
drugged Hunter Biden they gave they get
they drugged him gave him prostitutes
they distracted him which you know I
understand under Biden kind of gets
distracted by drugs and prostitutes I
mean who wouldn't really I mean come on
I'm not I'm not gonna lie I might get a
little distracted if I was coked up and
doing prostitutes it might happen but
what I'm saying is is that what he's
saying is it happened in Kazakhstan
Fatima so they set it up to where they
wouldn't have as much legal exposure
right if it did come back on them they
made sure of that that was the whole
point of having this all done to Hunter
Biden bring it to Delaware and then some
some Rando dropping it off at this
Delaware repair shop that way Rudy
Giuliani knew it was going to that
[__] Delaware repair shop and he
could get access through law enforcement
so that's probably the answer to the
question but I will tell you that it
feels like to me I don't know just to me
that luck is running out on all this
[__] criming that they're doing it
really is it really is and speaking of
criming speaking of criming and the
Donald Trump crimes I tell you what I'll
tell you what Gabe Sanchez
they can't stop talking about Donald
Trump crimes they can't stop talking
about it like it's all they talk about
for the last [__] week and it's
probably all they're going to talk about
for the next two months and it makes me
so happy that I don't hear gas stoves
that I don't hear gas prices and egg
prices and inflation they're only
talking about how much crime Donald
Trump is doing and I have a special
guest I have a special guest with us
here to talk about this messaging and
this narrative and how we're going to
drive it now we're going to keep
pounding the drum right after this break
Dr Rachel bittickoffer right after this
we'll be right back mark
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose babblemaga Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show as
promised my favorite political
strategist on the planet
the best at it doubt me
the [__] best no one holds the
candles the doctorates a bit of copper
when it comes to messaging and strategic
outrage
and I have her here today to talk to you
about how we are going to keep driving
this message and keep letting Maga talk
about how much crime Trump is uh is
committing Dr Rachel bidikoffer welcome
back to the show it's great to have you
man I feel like Taylor Swift with that
intro dude should I try diving off the
stage and swimming in the you know
Middle East
they said they said there was going to
be more people in Arizona for the Taylor
Swift debut than there was in the Super
Bowl well I never really thought about
popping tabs to go see a Swifty show but
hell man gonna have [__] like that it's
pretty tempting and I thought you were
going to say there were more people at
the Taylor Swift concert than they were
that were trying to protest Donald
Trump's indictment but you know that
well I've got a great I got a great
video of uh of some protest well I mean
or the lack of yeah as a free tip though
if you're gonna try to rally a mob to
save you from jail do not do it during
March Madness okay
well I mean that could be a good idea
I'll tell you man that's not the time to
rally the troops up
of that in their messaging because on
Saturday he's like I'm gonna get
arrested on Tuesday make sure that make
sure you go protest protest protest and
then they figured out that there wasn't
going to be a protest so Monday the
Republicans are like don't go protests
don't go protest don't go protest that
way they go like see we told them not to
and they listened to us yeah okay right
I mean it kind of it it I wouldn't be
surprised if we hear the narrative
because Donald Trump says oh on Tuesday
I'm going to be arrested which even his
own team and also people from the DA's
office were like we would never give you
a date beforehand look well once we have
the indictment
then we'll coordinate in the Secret
Service with everything
so the idea that he was like oh on
Tuesday we're gonna do this we're I'm
gonna get arrested the greatest present
your favorite President right so not
only do we waste taxpayer money in New
York right that has to get extra support
and and uh you know the the police force
and other areas
within New York but then also they have
to be like oh [__] is this really going
to happen and if it doesn't happen then
Donald Trump works the narrative he says
look I wasn't indicted on Tuesday do
they really have a case guys no they
don't and that I guarantee is what
they're going to push and be like look
it didn't happen Tuesday so Alvin Bragg
is really struggling to find something
here and of course that's not the case
because if Donald Trump just making [__]
up right yeah no doubt I mean you know I
I thought a couple of things from this
Tuesday announcement I think I honestly
do think that Donald Trump thought like
the Maga faithful would come flocking to
the streets of DC and New York and
wherever else and like they'd be this
now like the women's March that's what
he expected right
oh [__] no I'm not going to jail for you
again
well all the ones that were willing to
be violent are already arrested or
indicted or in prison
more too dude okay they just put out
like a week before he did that tweet
they they put out an article about how
doj has about a thousand more Rank and
file prosecutions to push through [__]
yeah probably halfway through all of
those hundreds of prosecutions they have
another foul on their radar and you can
bet that those people know who they are
yeah
well let's talk about the messaging in
the narrative because Maga can't stop
talking about Trump crimes and I love it
me too they can't stop and really
honestly it's him that's doing this to
himself because he keeps talking about
it I mean I don't know how many rage
posts he put up this morning on fraud
social but it was a lot
um and it keeps coming like he keeps
saying the same [__] he keeps typing the
same [__] he made a video that we played
yesterday where he was like this crime
is this crime and this crime
okay yeah let's list them all buddy so
they can't stop talking about it and and
it seems like they've laid the gas
stoves and the inflation aside because
all's Jim Jordan and Jim Comer and all
these Republicans Kevin McCarthy
um it it feels like it feels like Donald
Trump is still the head of their party I
don't know maybe it's just me
um and that's why they can't stop
talking about his crime because he can't
stop talking about it no no they can't
shake him he's like herpes man once you
kiss that cow you're gonna be in forever
right so
um you know here's the thing Tony you
nailed it right on your intro bringing
me on every day that the news cycle is
about Donald Trump's you know serial
criminality is a day that we will win in
2023 right and and I know a lot of
people don't understand that they think
well you know oh shouldn't the attention
be on infrastructure or all these things
Democrats are doing and I'm like no
every day that the news cycle is about
them and their [__] show figurehead uh
it it is good for us right so like we
we're really pleased I'm really pleased
that Donald Trump created a 48 I guess
we're going on 72-hour news cycle now
out of thin air that you know proved a
he has no ability to summon a mob okay
it's gone and and I think Lawrence
O'Donnell did a great job the other
night just calling that out like no one
is coming he is not yeah well I mean but
Rachel let me ask you because I I was
thinking about this and I'm thinking
because I thought oh maybe there will be
some protests maybe there will be a
little bit of violence and then I
thought who's gonna show up at Tucker
Carlson's viewers Newsmax viewers oh I
mean what are they going to show up with
their walkers and their canes their
oxygen machines and if you look at what
we've seen that some of these these cult
Nazi rallies that he does these people
aren't it's more like professional
wrestling fans it really feels like
maybe they believe some of this stuff
but more it's about the theatrics of it
these people aren't gonna go and and
commit violence for him in the in in New
York City of all places really come on
did we expect this it's ridiculous
but a God I would love if they would
like to go to New York City because
everybody that goes in and out of that
town gets you know the real ID and the
photo recognition [__] and the license
scan and I mean it's the most heavily
militarized city in America in terms of
surveillance right so please Maga by all
means if you decided to skip CPAC
because you rightly thought the FBI
would be there looking for you go to New
York go to Park House right on the
streets of Manhattan go have at it I'm
not worried about that and we have to
stop being cowed by this man I I talked
about him being a puffer fish right he's
all big cheeks it's all Bluster and
fakeness and you can really see that now
because all these years all these
decades that he's used this tough man
Persona to evade you know accountability
now that it's really knocking at the
door he is shaking in his knees and all
he comes off as is a scared sad old man
and I think it's really finally pulling
back fact that that curtain that we
create we've created and I think we're
never Trump is especially prone to this
this myth of this in salable you know
um Don Teflon Don image okay and it's it
could be further than the truth the only
thing that's ever made Donald Trump
um you know Invincible is our our belief
that he is right and we we need to break
that that psychosis and I think a couple
other people are talking very clearly
about the weakness of this Maga moment
it's not a strong movement this is a
movement that is on its heels uh it
still has a lot of elected power and
therefore it's a huge threat to us in
terms of policy and and what we're going
to see with this debt ceiling hostage
situation but the end of the day like
Donald Trump is not in a position of
strength and though Republicans might
like to go on TV and talk about how this
is going to help him win the election
dude there ain't no strategists in that
party but things boy you know what we
really need is Donald Trump facing
indictments in Georgia New York and
federally for overthrowing the
government because damn that's going to
work with swing voters you know like so
that's my thoughts on it and you know I
think it remains to be seen if we're
going to see an indictment I I just saw
something on the online about there's no
meeting now today for the jury I don't
know if you know anything about that
yeah yeah so they're gonna we reported
that but I mean yesterday there was bomb
threats as the judge traveled down the
tis James proceeding so who know maybe
there's some more um threats or
something and that's why they're being
cautious I mean really and I think we
are going to see that just to be clear
like we're not going to see a storming
event but we're going to see a lot of
Lone Wolf crazies and it and it doesn't
here I'm not going to say it doesn't
matter especially because I'm not the
law enforcement I have to go toe-to-toe
with these people and hopefully not
their targets right
um so it's easy for me to say this but I
will say this like it is not something
that's insurmountable and if and if
people are willing to do do that now
just imagine what they will do with
power so you know whatever the cost is
going to be for accountability it is a
price that we as a country should be
eager to pay now before it ends up being
the kind of Bill that bankrupts us
well I want to talk a little bit about
mangas and what they're talking about
and some of the ridiculous arguments
that they're making because I think it's
delicious
um I've been in this Twitter space we
should get you in there maybe
um to tear apart these people
um it's it's absolutely fun to listen to
these delusional moglodytes uh just
absolutely have the dumbest arguments
Tom Benton was in on Saturday uh when he
announced this we were in there with
seven he was also he also came in on
Monday too yeah we were in there with
Seb Gorka and Tom Finn and I got up to
the plate and I said Tom did you look in
the mirror and and say your argument out
loud to yourself before you came on here
and repeated it today because you're
saying two things you're saying that
this is going to propel and guarantee
that Donald Trump is the president
United States but Prosecuting him will
destroy the country so are you telling
me that propelling him to the president
of the United States is going to destroy
the country because it feels like that's
what you're saying he lost his mind on
me he lost his mind and Seb lost his
mind too but the other argument that I
think they're making which is absolutely
crazy is this it's all political it's
all political of course it's political
he was running a political campaign he
played a political payment
he made it almost every single
investigation that Donald Trump is
facing right now has to do with his
politics and his political campaigns and
his and him overthrowing the government
are trying to overthrow the government
so he could win even though he lost in
Georgia in in January 6 it's he stole
our documents to possibly cover up his
crimes I mean his political crimes I
mean of course it's politics he's a
politician he's the former president
United States yeah it's about politics I
just don't get how they don't they can't
I mean I know what they're saying is
Alan Bragg is it's politics to him but
he's an elected official too
I mean you know let's just the best way
to dissect their [__] argument about
politics is to do the counter factual
okay well if politicians can't be
prosecuted for crimes because it might
look political then that means the
entire political class is above the law
right I mean so you what you really need
to be doing is reminding these people of
the core simple Central fact do the
crime do the time no one is above the
law and you know they've been shoving
that [__] down our throats for a couple
decades right they're a tough one well
do the crime do the time Law and Order
Law and Order yeah yeah so what I
recommend is instead of defending the
appropriateness of the charges right you
go on a counter offense and tell them
you know what you don't care about the
rule of law in America do you think
Donald Trump is above the law why do you
think Republicans are immune from the
law right and when them explain their
positions because it's one thing to ask
somebody do you think Donald Trump
should be prosecuted for whatever the
other question though the one that the
way you should be forcing people to
answer the question that makes them
answer is are you saying Donald Trump
didn't commit these crimes right I mean
are you discounting this evidence right
should we just ignore all of the crimes
that Donald Trump yes that's exactly
right no that's honestly like Tom Finn
and other people their their argument is
any charges any charges that Come Donald
Trump's way from this investigation
doesn't matter we should not even
consider them as legitimate this is a
[__] case right it's not real he
didn't commit a crime which again also
brings into a lot of question of this
idea of like before Donald Trump saying
I never had an affair or I never paid
her I never did this or I never did that
right and now it's coming to this point
like Donald Trump is at this interesting
kind of fork in the road he either
admits that he did have this affair or
had sex with Stormy Daniels and the
reason he paid her off was be because he
didn't want Melania to find out or the
reason he paid off Stormy Daniels
was because of a political incentive
right he didn't want voters to find out
about this because it would ruin his
campaign so either way so it's
interesting also to see Republicans try
to figure out how to do this like
gymnastics routine of well he's not
guilty but he
[__] okay so he did sleep
like it's they're having this hard time
trying to figure out okay now they're
now they say okay fine he did have sex
with her right but that's totally fine
because religious people are totally
fine now now what we've heard in these
spaces as well is there are people on
there
who are admitting that Donald Trump a is
not religious and and and B is now
admitting the fact that the people who
were religious that voted him in knew
about him doing these creepy things when
he was running in 2016 and they
essentially compromised on their values
but that's okay and they're totally okay
with it and right now as he's running
for reelection in uh 2024 it's totally
fine they've accepted that he's just
like you know not great person
especially on someone who has you know
cheated on his wife and those are things
that you shouldn't do especially if
you're you know someone who's religious
or Christian or Evangelical or whatever
so it's interesting to see them try to
juggle they're like well he did but he
but he did but there's and it's they
kind of break down the logic on how
they've shifted and and when they try to
make an argument they'll do one
and then they'll also play the other
side as well which is like you guys got
to pick a lane here again you have to
figure out is he guilty or is he not
guilty that's interesting I think the
other thing that's interesting is how
they're focusing on the hush money
payment which I don't think this case is
about at all right um I I actually it
look it seems like that it's not
actually about the actual payment or the
act of what she did and he did in the
room or whatever they did rather they
[__] or she did what or he did what I
don't think it's about any of that all
but they're focused on that and I
believe that's that's honestly a better
situation at this point because these
charges are going to come down it's
probably not going to have to do with
whatever action happened in that room
and it's gonna startle them and it's
gonna slip their narrative away it's
going to slip their plot line away from
them even further which is what we need
to continue to do Rachel is is let them
have their plot line slipped away from
them
yeah I mean God love you for going into
spaces with some oh it's it's horrible
there's no way that I would ever do that
with you
God love you for doing that but here's
you know here's the thing you got to
remember like I mean one of the reasons
I don't waste time with Maga people
trying to like rationalize with them is
that they can't be rationalized they are
victims of a mass site a targeted
decades-long Mass psychosis right dark
psychology operation so my new system
actually is whatever the hell they say I
just respond with get a therapist and
when you hire him please tell him you
have been the target of a decades-long
dark psychology operation and now you're
in a cult
try that well we'll try that in the
space
because speaking of hiring a therapist
Donald Trump has been hiring some
lawyers I don't know where he gets these
Cracker Jack people but they keep going
on Ari melbour's show
um and it is [__] hilarious listen to
this one here I don't know who this
cheese head is here this guy I don't
know I don't know who this guy is or
where he's from it's very strange watch
watch what he says and watch how Ari
um someone said today why do these
people go on as the nail when Ari brings
the hammer it doesn't make any sense but
watch this
but that's what I stay focused on do you
ignore the Donald Trump lost the Georgia
election
I I'm I am that's a good that's an easy
one true no no I'm I'm focused let me
tell you what I'm focused on I'm focused
on being a criminal defense attorney and
seeing that my client is being swept up
and what his to me been a ridiculous
circus atmosphere special purpose grand
jury and you made that point but in this
case not only in this case but on other
cases do you acknowledge to sit there do
you ignore it here
other political people
why not even why would we even talk
about that what does that have to do
what does it have to do with me
defending president Trump in this matter
I appreciate it all right it does you've
raised a rhetorical question what does
that have to do let's listen to Donald
Trump lying to people some of whom later
committed crimes some of whom other
Republicans committed the the potential
crime of misleading the government about
who were the duly stated electors of
Georgia which of course the current
president President Biden won here's
Donald Trump talking about Georgia take
a listen
you know we won Georgia just so you
understand they cheated and they rigged
our presidential election but we will
still win it
that was December 2020 that was a lie
and it was in concert with these other
things a lie that induced these people
to submit this elector fraud which may
or may not be charged in which as of
January 6 they were trying to bring some
of that in different states not Georgia
by the way to the floor of the Senate
that was been uncovered so again I I
want to give you one more chance on that
when you say you don't know why it's
relevant that's to me the most terrible
way I can put it through is that's
confusing because what's relevant is the
entire point that he lost the election
and got people to submit false material
to the government and everywhere else or
conspire to do so and that's a potential
crime now it it's so so Ari let me tell
you because what I'm not going to do is
I'm not going to be a hypocrite and I'm
not going to be
um okay well I mean it's obvious that
this guy um he got him on I don't know
if there's a website that has uh like I
don't know I mean my characters where
you can cast these uh Beetlejuice
looking uh attorneys or not but he's got
a whole cast of characters here
apparently the one we saw last week I
think his name is Taco penis everyone's
talking about he was on Ari's show he
was grabbing Ari Melbourne's penis yeah
he was grabbing Ari melber by the facts
um Ari melber had the receipts in his
hand and he was grabbing Ari melber by
the facts and this guy this Beetlejuice
looking [__] so I don't know if
these are actually Representatives or
Donald Trump is just hiring these people
to go on MSNBC I'm not really sure um
but Rachel what do you what do you take
from it is I mean all this stuff's a
joke but they make it more of a joke
when they're trying to make it look
better and is this just to make Donald
Trump feel good about a Ari melber show
that he clearly watches because he sends
these people on there
I mean Ari's Cascade of stupid attorneys
Mega attorneys to me is again why we
have to have we have to [__] have
accountability here these people are so
terrible at crime even their attorneys
go on TV and give interviews about
ongoing investigations right and there's
there's no way that we can have America
collapse under the weight of this
dumbassness right and I love Ari because
like you know the first few lawyers I
mean it was back during the Mueller gate
stuff that he lured on there or or
suspects that he learned on the live TV
and he's a trained attorney by the way
so it's not like you're going on against
you know Rachel Maddow who's very shrewd
and sharp but not a lawyer right Ari Ari
not only is a lawyer he's a I think he's
a good one he's a very good one but
Jesus I mean it's like taking candy out
of a babies
right
Costello stuff was so great the other
night and and to answer your question
Tony if you think about Maga and you
take it for its real meaning making
attorneys get attorneys right and you
look at prompts you know pool of hirable
talent yo I mean TV lawyer from the
phone book has got to be what he's down
to the last kind of somewhat real
attorneys he purchased are all facing
Federal time now for you know classified
documents so well that's supposedly be
encouraging and on top of all of that
you may not get paid so it's one thing
to be like oh I'll take them I'll take
the money at least I need the money you
know I mean this is a guy who bounces
checks so yeah I don't expect that he's
going to be well represented
um I don't know maybe some somebody will
will step up for these Federal and
serious felonies but you know who's he
gonna get it's just so hard because he
makes you commit crimes and eventually
we're going to start to see these
lawyers going down for him so well that
is one one more question that I have for
you before you leave is that the Jack
Smith is moving fast because this is the
other little narrative that they have
going and really I think the left the
left or liberals have kind of bought
this narrative which is really dumb
um that oh the case in Manhattan is a
weak case and oh the Jack Smith case is
so much better but we see Jack Smith it
looks like he's moving very rapidly
towards an obstruction charge
um and and there's always the
possibility with the special counsel
that have super scene indictments I
think people forget that or they don't
know that
um I think Jack Smith is going to strike
hard here we watched as over the last 24
hours the appeals court or the appeals
judges say hey get us this these
whatever they are these documents now
and then you have six hours to respond
you got six hours to get us these
documents and you have six hours to
respond so something's moving fast and
there's a reason for it and I doubt that
it's
that Donald Trump likes to delay that
timing just seems uh suspicious to me
that that's the reason it feels like to
me that the P the the reporters out
there saying hey this has something to
do with National Security are the
experts out there because this does have
to do with classified documents I kind
of believe that more now that the court
has seen what the crime products
exemption is and why he lied to his
attorney and what he lied to him about
it's of National Security interest
that's why they're moving fast and
that's why they want to move fast so it
feels like to me that Jack Smith is
walking very very rapidly to an
obstruction cars but my charge but my my
question is this does it really matter
in our narrative which who comes first
and which indictment is first and how
many they are do we really give a [__]
about this or or is it just about him
[__] finally being held accountable
even if we don't see a trial just to
start the accountability process isn't
that really what is going to drive our
narrative well yeah keep in mind I mean
somehow we've evolved a political
culture in the country in which we had a
Revolution and the biggest concern of
the people who shaped the government was
how to keep power from consolidating to
corruption right in this world we've
somehow created this myth of an
unindictable president ex-president and
it's just so absurd right so I think
it's really time for us to um you know
Hammer them and honestly I don't care
who which indictment goes first my
thought is if it's an easy indictment
good right because then or a lower crime
indictment good because maybe it will
send a message to doj right and if I
really do feel like the states have to
lead the Department of Justice on this
so to me I don't care who goes first I
feel like the damn will break as long as
somebody goes first so for me um you
know I'm feeling pretty optimistic about
heading into the fall with a four-time
at least you know four four venue and
indicted president former president
Donald Trump well I couldn't agree with
you more in speaking about the fall I'm
excited about your book I know I talk
about it when you come on here and we're
going to keep talking about it I am very
excited about your book so give us a
Shameless plug here for the audience
um we got a few more videos we got to
watch so I appreciate you joining us but
give us a Shameless plug of where they
can find you and what they expect when
they find you there yeah so this book is
coming out by a crown in the fall it
doesn't have its release date or its
cover yet but as soon as it does I'll be
sharing that extensively on my socials
and it's called hit them where it hurts
how to save democracy by beating
Republicans at their own game and it
teaches
um people regular people all the way up
to campaign professionals how to go
toe-to-toe against a propaganda machine
well go follow Rachel uh Dr Rachel
bittickoffer at Rachel bittickoffer on
Twitter you'll find all her links there
and like like I said you gotta go look
at the tweets not only is this book
coming out but every day she gives you a
lesson in messaging a narrative and how
to beat back against Maga as it were on
her Twitter account every single day she
is typing them in and she is tweeting
the [__] out of the messaging in the
narrative that you must know and you
must carry with you every single moment
as you're as you're defending your
democracy as always my friend Dr Rachel
bittickoffer thank you for joining us I
hope to see you soon great seeing you
guys see ya everyone sit around everyone
stick around we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show gate Sanchez I
have some breaking news I got some
pictures
no today is not supposed to be
indictment day but I don't know maybe
this is just AI pictures maybe it's
actual photos I posted this on Twitter
people like this is fake
this is fake well it's obvious that it's
fake
duh of course of course these images are
fake of course they are here's here they
are they're of Donald Trump running so
those are those are real they're so real
that Donald Trump was able to hold his
own Baton on his belt yeah there it is
right there so I I think this is um I
don't know where these images I I found
this I believe they're uh their
mid-journey AI okay so this is AI it's
another software that okay I get you it
does yeah
um but and the this AI does not
understand that Donald Trump can't run
yeah there's no way no way dudes running
like that no [__] dude this is a
full-on Sprint look at that right I mean
that's like good running
you know this is like you know I got the
no no way this guy can't run more than
10 yards it's funny because people like
this is fake I'm like yeah no [__]
Sherlock like there's no way that's a
real picture of him when's the last time
you've seen a picture of him where he
was in the shape to run yeah come on
come on of course it's fake but I mean
it's I I like it how did we switch oh
there we go oh whoa I don't know what
happened we're on the wrong side ah
let's see
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm making [__] dizzy
um
oh my God so there is um
there's no people um protesting in New
York or down nobody showed up well there
is there okay there were some people
there are some there is a wish.com
um
chewing on Shaman did you see this video
of this of this um
I don't know what it is I don't know you
tell me what what let's now apparently
this is uh this is a hoax right it's not
really a q9 shaman he's not really
well no I'm I don't know who this is
It's just he's obviously tried to dress
up like the Q Anon Shaman it's I think
it's a spoof you know like when Walter
goes and dresses up as Maga or something
yeah yeah I think it's kind of the same
thing here
um but the TR the guy talking to him is
a trump supporter I mean the one guy
that did show up in New York to to you
know protest I guess other than this guy
who's fake protesting but watch this
this is hilarious
[Music]
[Applause]
that's why I'm here that's why I put on
all this stuff
like you look crazy you look like a
psycho yeah you say you are all the
boxes boom you're a trump supporter yeah
this is [__] wild man because I had
to watch that three or four times to
figure out whoa whoa whoa who's the
Trump supporter in this video and who is
pissed off at who so this is what
they're doing at the protest in New York
I mean if you want to call it that it
seemed like there was more onlookers
there with cameras to record this to put
it on social media than there were
protesters like literally there's
there's like 15 people standing around
three people who are protesting filming
them doing this stuff
um to post it on social media so they
get a lot of clicks and Views I'm gonna
go with that's not an actual Trump
supporter the way which one which one
that's what I'm the one with the antlers
on oh really in the in the face no
there's
apparently this was outside the uh
Courthouse I guess
um so did you see um um I sent you a
video and Walter was at the very end of
it yeah yeah yeah yeah what was that was
that the uh problem
too that it was guys that were dressed
up as proud boys and they weren't
actually proud boys I think that's but
that's how it always goes right whenever
whenever Republicans right Wings you
know uh did you ever promise did you get
all the Walther and ask him and say hey
um were they proud boys or is it
[__] no I didn't I didn't ask him I
could I could send a message right now I
got you we should get him in that room
too we should get him in in their in the
spaces and the reason why is because
when they start talking about January
6th and they're like oh it was antifa
dressed up as dressed up as Trump
supporters they actually used a video
it's a comedy video it's a [__] spiff
all right spoof it's it's a satire it's
parody where um Walter is talking about
how they're gonna dress up to confuse
people and [__]
um which he actually does to get them to
talk to him not to commit crime just to
get them to talk to him like when he's
interviewing him which he showed up in
the January 6th select evidence that
they used in the committee because he
was interviewing someone
um in that very costume that he is in
the other video putting on but they use
that but it would be hilarious to listen
to Walter go in that room and [__] with
those people oh it would be [__]
hilarious to [__] with them when they're
like yeah it was aunties like yeah I'm
in a video as me or yeah
just totally through wrenches in their
plot I don't know I'm just saying but
there was an instance where a bunch of a
couple proud boys apparently showed up
at a protest and they got their asses
kicked I want to show you uh a picture a
video though speaking of uh protest and
drag queens and uh drag queen protest
they're trying to legislate our
countrymen our our fellow our fellow
humans out of existence and it's really
weird this whole narrative I said this
time and time again it's really [__]
weird that they think drag queens are
trans people right and it's not that
they can't be and it's not that they're
not allies they certainly are but it
they just fundamentally don't understand
any of the stuff they're talking about
right yeah like they just don't but um
as they push more legislation and as
they push more hate it's only giving
more people reason to actually make
these people they're trying to get rid
of celebrities in society um this is
actually excuse me this is in Nashville
I got one for you in Idaho okay okay
yeah yeah put it in the uh the thing
there now I'll put up um this is in an
arena okay now this this is not a story
hour where there's you know like um 15
people there this is in a [__] Arena
um and again uh tennis uh the Tennessee
holler points out that these laws that
you're passing to try to eradicate these
people or whatever you're trying to do
you [__] bigots your only you're only
giving them a higher platform and people
learning who they are and what they're
about and it's and and people are
learning that these are these are
communities that are loving and are
about love and that and that want to
teach children how to read and want to
teach children to be who they are and
and and it just doesn't make sense why
you're trying to push back on them
because you're only elevating you're
only elevating the love in their
community and showing people that
they're not but you know keep keep at it
keep at it if that's what you're gonna
do but here's here's a little uh um this
is in Tennessee by the way where they
have banned the possibility of this
watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd like to point out before we get to
the end because they do a couple of
close-ups here of of the performers here
and um I just I just want to point out
did that seem sexual to you and all oh
man that was so sexual right that was
right so [__] did you see did you see
how much skin those drag queens were
showing oh my God I could see all of
their face right and a little bit of
shoulders some of them had their arms
some of them had their arms Tony Tony
freaking man all right you know calm
down too much too much skin I'm just
saying I'm just saying well let's let's
continue
hi how you doing
[Applause]
you guys look great
did you see all that skin they were
showing look I'm gonna back it up a bit
look at all that skin oh my God and look
how sexual they're waving and blowing
kisses oh my God
how dare they be so God man Republicans
are just [__] awful do they even know
what sexually means do they know what
sexual means no they don't they they
don't Republicans think that it's any
Republicans think sexual is anything
that makes you feel uncomfortable right
and and I think that's where the oh no
no no oh no no no that's bad that's bad
it's like dude
calm the [__] down like are we are we
not are have we not gone back to a point
where now we have to fight for the
rights of the people that we we
we did years ago and unfortunately yeah
we have to do it right we have to stand
up and we we had a whole movement of of
civil rights inequality and now we are
back at that point where it's almost
like we have to pass new legislation
like sweeping legislation to protect the
very people that we were starting to
protect when we passed those those bills
initially right so the the amount of
like
there's a reason why they call the left
Progressive right you're progressing
forward you're taking strides to advance
our society for the better Republicans
are regressive they go back in time is
that what the r stands for that's that's
what the r stands for the Republican
stands for regressive well I got this
[__] right here I got regressive I got
representative rod from a regressive
republican from Rigby there's all kinds
of R's with this [__]
um now this is in Idaho you said isn't
that right this is Idaho this is not a
video of a drag queen apparently no this
is a guy trying to eradicate
um trans people lgbtq people and using
drag queens as a lever to do it maybe
let's listen to this yeah just a little
bit different but you'll see why let's
see what the regressive republican from
Rigby Rod has to say boys and girls have
two P's peeing and pooping we know that
the proper did he just did he just say I
haven't watched this no yeah yeah I told
you I told you it's it's it's not along
the same lines as that but it is still
attacking I'm gonna I'm gonna go back to
the beginning because I thought I
thought he said they have two P's and I
thought he was gonna say
you know what I thought he was going to
say but but he said he said peeing and
pooping what what does that happen no
we're bringing it we're bringing in the
kid talk now what the [__] is he talking
about okay well let's let's yeah just
wait just wait let's go boys and girls
have two P's peeing and pooping we know
that the proper role of government is to
cover the two P's well surprise we just
figured out 2023 the girls have three
p's oh my God okay so we were just
talking about how they have ours and now
he's talking about peas how does that
how did that even happen did you plan
that because I didn't plan that nope I
didn't oh my God
so he's saying they have three p's okay
let's let's hear what he thinks the the
the
crusty white old ball sack let's see
what he knows about the three we three
p's of what girls have Okay let's listen
to your advice let's go yeah peeing and
pooping in Period oh my [__] God I
told you I told you man this [__] is um
I almost bet I haven't seen this video
but I almost bet he gets everything
about like women's anatomy and biology
and health care and all kinds of [__]
just completely [__] wrong what what
am I I mean I don't know I mean you're
you're not off the mark okay let's let's
listen now we can hold the first two P's
peeing and pooping we can take care of
that
but the third P the girls don't have a
muscle down there when that happens it
happens it's well he's talking about the
third B that must be that must be period
right is what he's talking about yep
who is this [__] this guy
gynecologist I want to know nope he's
not a gynecologist no well so what would
he know what would he know about uh
Women's Health Care and women's issues
what the [__] would he know about their
bodies
he's an American businessman he's a
patriot yeah I'm a man I'm America First
Nazi okay I knows everything about them
periods listen I don't know [__] about
women's periods not a [__] thing
that's right Tony Michaels doesn't know
a goddamn thing about women's periods
because I isn't one and I don't stick my
nose in your business about your health
care and your things that you got to
deal with all right I'm not asking the
regressive republican from Rigby the
Republican representative Rod I'm not
asking about his [__] his issues down
there why is he asking about theirs but
let's
yeah we still got a little bit of video
here let's see what else he um gets
wrong it's an emergency every time that
happens it's a basic biological function
is the proper role of government to
cover of basic biological function I
submit to you that it is the p word
that's in my word in my head right now
is patronized as a woman we're capable
of handling these things we look out for
each other I think it's a stretch to say
that we have to provide these products
in order for women to be educated
there's another p word and that p word
is parents and if the schools get
between the daughter and the parents
then there may be some important
conversations that don't take place this
bill is a very liberal policy and it's
really turning Idaho into a bigger Nanny
State than ever okay so I don't know
what this bill is but I'm getting the
sense from these are Republicans that
are talking about the peace
of little girls it feels like to me that
the state of Idaho that the Democrats of
State Idaho want to make sure that that
young young women uh have access to
education and probably things that they
need for Hygiene uh for this biological
issue as they're calling it is that am I
wrong is that what is that the bill yeah
so this is uh hold on let me it feels
like that's what yeah I'll read you the
exact language of it so they're
discussing this tampon bill which I
believe that he's insupportive but the
way in which he's discussing it is the
most [__] back ass backwards [__]
I've ever heard all right give one
second all right so Idaho Republicans
reject this liberal policy for free free
menstrual uh uh products in public
schools right like if you're a woman
you're a female you go into the bathroom
you should be the nurse's office
wherever like you'd have to build like
if you don't have one or let's say that
oh wait wait wait see this see this is
me being of my ignorance that's why I
don't get involved in these That's why
when the when when the one uh
representative was talking about like
you know women are there to help each
other like you might find that moment
where like oh I don't have a tampon and
maybe you're a classmate or another
person in class has it but this is the
ability like
a machine like a machine but here's the
thing it shouldn't just be free in
schools tampon should be free for anyone
anyone who needs them public
schools private schools public
facilities wherever it is this is
something that should be accessible to
ever there should be a U.S socialist
what are you saying I am I am what are
you some kind of tampon socialist
anyways you want health care and and and
are you you're horrible uh tampon
socialist I'm sorry man I can't but what
I will say is so according to this house
bill 313 yeah it was rejected on Monday
and it would have funded free mental
products in public school bathrooms the
GOP House member said that a proposal
was liberal and they objected to woke
terms describing inaccessibility to
tampons and pads okay oh wait you're
going to be the guy wait wait so you're
saying the guy in the beginning of the
video is for this Bill yes okay
something makes me sponsored it okay so
something makes me think here that
something's a foot it makes me believe
here's what it makes me believe is that
the the Republican dude who is
sponsoring this wants to know about
young women's menstrual cycles he wants
to know it's possible it's it's honestly
like I and the Republican women right no
it's tampon socialism they can't decide
you know I've been saying that they're
losing the plot line This is the weeds
that they get in when they are talking
about [__] they don't [__] understand
right and and the women are like hey man
this they're trying to call it a liberal
policy well let's continue yeah and
let's continue and then you can tell us
about the rest of the law it's
embarrassing not only because of the
topic because of but because of the
actual policy itself so you don't have
to be a woman
to understand the in the absurdity to
this policy and you don't have to feel
that you're insensitive to not address
this what's going to be next because uh
we have what toilet paper we have paper
towels what is she arguing is she
arguing oh my God we're providing toilet
paper and paper towels to people
now what the [__] she's arguing
so you're supposed to not be able to
wipe your ass
is that it's just you know look uh you
got those two things they're good and I
don't understand
I mean oh oh is she oh okay so maybe I'm
misunderstanding she's saying use the
paper towels and the toilet paper to
make a makeshift tampon is that what I
don't know how this works no let's see
let's see what it says let's see let's
see what he says let's see
um the the good gentleman says well they
can't help it the women can't help the
the having their periods well what about
sweat we can't help sweat so are the
schools now going to be providing
deodorant for these kids
oh my God what the [__] are they what
the hell are they arguing about what the
[__] like listen listen listen
I agree that we should provide people
with basic hygiene products I mean
toilet paper paper towels being a few of
them tampons
um other other products might be
toothpaste toothbrushes probably soap I
don't I I'm not against if if a child
goes to the nurse's office at their
public school and says hey I don't have
any soap at home they give them a couple
bars of soap and a bottle of shampoo I'm
not against that hell let them take a
shower I know that there are schools
around the country that have showers at
their schools that they let the kids
take showers at because they don't have
showers at home to take showers
what are they arguing about I don't
understand the fact that this woman who
just spoke at the end as a woman mind
you as a woman and I'm sure she has
experienced this as well right as I'm
sure as other women have experienced
this in the chat
the when somebody well again did you
just use toilet paper or can't you just
use a paper towel it's like a look dude
that [__] doesn't absorb anything right
it it does not have the same absorption
qualities that a tampon or a pad would
have right like that's not something
that you would use in that situation I
mean maybe if it was an extreme and
you're like I don't have anything then
maybe but it doesn't have the same
qualities or benefits that you would get
from something like a tampon right
um
so when you see people like Rod furnas
at the beginning right who sponsored
this bill that seems sus to me which is
weird right because it would have funded
and let me just I'll read for you the
the breakdown of this it would have
funded no cost menstrual product
dispensers in public school bathrooms
for 6th through 12th grade students
right so those are the ages in junior
high and high schools exactly right uh
you're in the public schools and this is
the typical age range where you would
need to use those things so we should
make them accessible the estimated price
tag was 435 in one time state general
funds to install the dispensers and
about boys
go ahead and about 300 000 annually to
stock them according to their fiscal
note uh that's about three dollars and
fifty cents per student God forbid we
spend or invest in this but whatever
state budget analysts predict Ohio will
have a 1.4 billion dollar tax revenue
Surplus at the end of the fiscal year so
it's not like they they don't have money
and it's not like they wouldn't save
them money right and it's not as if like
oh God forbid we actually care for other
people women especially who are going
through this in their lives and need oh
that would be great I could go from the
dispenser I could get one for free don't
have to worry about it don't have to
worry about embarrassment or fear that I
don't have one in my purse or that my
friend doesn't have one or that I have
to even ask someone to be like oh do you
have a tampon or something like those
are conversations that happen every day
but to avoid those moments right to
avoid it to be like great I have peace
of mind knowing if I go into the
bathroom there's going to be one stock
in the dispenser
but unfortunately these people
think that this is not a big deal right
and the ability for furnace this guy at
the beginning to say uh he goes it's not
a lot of money in the state's budget
totally today's a step forward in
Womanhood it gives a chance to start
start right not to be embarrassed or
feel alien or ashamed or to feel like
they need to stay home at school due to
a period poverty right which is again
I'm
so confused that this guy would bring up
the peas right three p's and this and
that like he doesn't quite know what
he's talking about here but he is
funding his bill so I'm very confused as
like how this is working like good I
mean it makes me well it makes me
suspicious about his motivation but I
don't I don't know like you always
listen you always got to be watching
these [__] and what they're
talking about you always got to be
watching and I'm going to show you a
photo here that was posted by acen on
Twitter speaking of this you gotta you
gotta watch these [__] what
they're talking about because um Sean
Hannity and Fox News has been trying to
break up Michael Cohen's credibility and
as we leave here I want to show you this
picture
um it seems like
Sean Hannity no it's Michael going a
little bit uh Eason says Hannity was has
devoted most of his show so far to
attacking Michael Cohen's credibility
here's an image he won't show during his
tonight's show did you know what the
funny part is is that even though Sean
Hannity is saying Michael Cohen is a
[__] liar and you can't trust
anything Michael Cohen says did you know
that Sean Hannity hired Michael Cohen
for Legal Services did you know that no
God damn yes he did no yep
um so if anyone says that [__] you just
try to make sure they know that
um who who was still seeking Michael
Cohen's Services even though they knew
he was a liar he's a known liar for a
long time okay well okay yeah yeah all
right I got you I follow you there
um one other thing I want to show you
before we leave here
um and we're gonna we're gonna handle
some business here but one other thing I
want to show you okay uh it is a clip if
I can find it back here damn it where
the hell they go
always with these with the and oh yes
apparently
um Rudy Giuliani has been making weird
phone calls to folks oh yeah yeah he
facetimes and I think you you recorded
him FaceTiming you and yeah so I'm gonna
show I want to show this to the audience
here
um the FaceTime that that he he did with
you
oh damn it this is Rudy Giuliani I know
Rudy I have caller ID behind me is a
baseball field where are you calling me
from I am in Manchester New Hampshire
are you on the run because of trump you
got a little better look at it Rudy can
we do this another time I'm sick and I
just want to go home and have some tea
I'm a little teapot short and stuff I
said I was sick and I want some tea not
I want you to sing me the teapot song
Here's my handle
here's my spout Rudy I'm not in the mood
for whatever this is right now when I
get all steamed up hear me shout damn it
Rudy what did I just say tip me over and
pour me out what is wrong with you there
is absolutely nothing wrong has anyone
ever conducted a wellness check on you
you'd be a good boy huh and if you want
to get in touch with me nope wow that
guy has really lost it
so there's there's Rudy's face time to
give something just saying he missile
you did he miss die I don't dude I get I
get here I will say this I get calls
from Rudy Giuliani yeah Kimberly
Guilfoyle Donald Trump Jr all of these
people and I make sure to record them
and if I I'm I'm gonna do a Shameless
plug here
but if you want to see more of these
types of videos you can find them on my
patreon I'm starting to do them I'm
bringing them back so I'll be doing them
more and more and more there is there is
tons of phone calls I get from them in
addition to what was that episodes
there's a ton more content like this and
other sketches but these FaceTime calls
I get them all the time guys sign up and
you'll see them yourself go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez that's
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez and while
you're over on patreon visit my page too
check out what we're doing over there
but boy I I tell you what um I'm getting
close to my my next goal I've got 173
members over there we're trying to work
to 250 and Gabe looks like you're 44
what's your goal is your goal for your
first goal 50 I'll go with 50. okay
let's get here's the thing that's not
starting low I started with 50. listen
you're you're at 44 right now folks out
there if you are listening go check out
Gabe's page over on patreon help him out
let's see if we can get him to 50 today
he's at 44 right now that shouldn't be
that difficult I'm not saying you'll get
me to 250 I'm at 173 but you know help
me out too go check out the page just
check it out just see what you think see
what's going on over there now check out
our or content that we make on patreon
we appreciate all the support there also
don't forget to subscribe right here on
YouTube at the Tony Michaels podcast
it's free patreon maybe a few bucks but
subscribing here for the show two hours
every single weekday is absolutely free
you can also follow us on Twitter and
download
every single episode for free 99 on
Apple Spotify Google or just download it
on all of them at the same time also
follow us follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels where we broadcast we also
broadcast from the up wires YouTube
channel go to the upward.com and then
also link your Amazon Prime account to
Twitch and give us that one free
subscription we get a few bucks every
month uh for Jeff bezos's Money listen
if you did do that and you get a lot of
you have almost 100 of you have I think
we're up to 90 some if you have done
that and you haven't renewed your
subscription you might want to go in to
the Twitch app and do that you have to
re-subscribe every month so you have to
re-give that free subscription every
month so make sure you're doing that
every month and give us that
subscription if you can that would be
great it's free for you to give us that
monetary support when you link your
Amazon Prime account to Twitch if you
don't know how to do it just go to
YouTube Type in link Amazon Prime
account to Twitch and there's a ton of
videos to show you super easy super
[__] easy
you can do it you can do it this is a
wave this is a special way for Chris he
asked for it oh Chris and Chris
Christmas it's for you bud uh welcome
welcome Chris he's uh one of the
original uh Watchers here he's kind of a
a low-lying troll we we appreciate Chris
here yeah go and meet Tony Michael's
podcast we don't turn away any trolls I
had one the other day holy moly one the
other day you should have heard what he
has a huge crush on me sent me an
Instagram yeah so we went so we were in
that Twitter space you should be I don't
know why you block out their name man
I just I just was showing people what he
was how he was crushing you got to show
the profile photo you got to show the
username I don't give a [__] about out
in this account the dude that's like the
dude has like one follower it's probably
it's probably his mom and then he's gay
if I was like 20 other people like what
the [__] like I just thought it was
funny that he has a huge crush on me
here's what happened he he was in the
Twitter space apparently because he was
talking about what I was saying in the
Twitter space [__] loves me so
much he jumped the platforms
so he left Twitter went to Instagram so
he can message me that's how much the
guy loves me it's cute
it's uh it's it's something I'll tell
you that oh yeah something right they're
they're um if you want to read it just
go follow me on Twitter and and don't
forget to follow us on Twitter at the
Tony Michaels and that I am Gabe Sanchez
I've been invited back into the Twitter
space room today I might oh they're no
they're not gonna do it today did they
shut it off yeah they're gonna postpone
because of the delay on the indictment
oh okay well they said this morning they
were gonna do it so I told them if I had
time I'd jump in so so maybe tomorrow
then yeah I got him I got a message
let me let me tell you though you still
want to go follow us on Twitter and
here's what you look for when you see
our when you see our Avatar and has a
white circle around it with the
microphone that means we are in a speed
space it doesn't mean we're speaking but
I think also if you do speak you get an
i
I don't know if you have to have the uh
the Bell notification uh set on on
Twitter
but I think that we are speaking right I
think if you're speaking then those
people get no like people who follow you
get notified and here's what I here's
what I did yesterday for uh all those on
patreon
um I went and posted the Twitter link on
patreon and I just said speaking now so
if you see that on patreon so that's why
you should go download the app if you're
a patreon member make sure you're
downloading the app logging in there so
you can see that um I'll let you know
over on patreon but I also retweeted the
um the room that we're in if we're if
I'm gonna speak I'll retweet if I'm not
gonna speak but I'm just in there
listening I'm not probably not going to
retweet it or say that I'm in there
because I'm not really and I'm just
listening I'm not I'm not gonna speak
um because I I really only come up to
the stage for the political stuff I
don't want to come up for the the Rudy
and the hunter Biden's laptop I mean I
love to make arguments and [__] yeah
you know throw [__] in their pot and
stir it around but you know it's just uh
I'll let I'll I'll let live it's rather
it's true or not true or he has the
evidence or doesn't have evidence is
[__] crazy it is crazy oh oh yeah
he's just he's just sitting at home just
right standing by right in in uh for
people who don't know love parness is at
home in house arrest so he's just
joining this space he's like I don't
give a [__] whatever right well because
he's still he's still under Federal uh
custody right so he's finishing up his
prison sentence at home
um is essentially you know he's in b.o.p
custody if he's on house arrest so yeah
um but um also I want to remind everyone
if you go to the YouTube channel make
sure you subscribe to the attorney
Michael's podcast YouTube channel we
posted the interview with Jess Jess
Piper the other day I cut it out and I
posted just the interview so you guys
can go watch that the thumbnail has
Sarah Huckabee Sanders on it and she
says get a job kid
um and it says
it says education labor laws
um so go check out that interview with
Jess Piper if you missed it the other
day it's in and of itself uh on the
YouTube channel and actually I'll have
some clips coming uh probably today or
tomorrow of that of us talking to her
and I'll post those on patreon first and
then over on social media so everyone go
check out all the things go follow our
go on our link trees all the all the
[__] is there it's all there all the
links are there so just go to the
tonymichaels.com and find all the links
there
we'll be back tomorrow for indictment
day fingers crossed I don't know what do
you think this is this is what I said
last week uh you're talking to some
people and I was like dude
I don't think it's going to happen this
week if it does it would happen at the
end of the week are you talking about
his arrest or indictment because those
are two different things indictment so I
think his indictment is going to happen
this week I think I think I think he's
going to self-surrender next week I
think the indictment and the arrest are
going to be so close together they are
so close together like maybe maybe a day
like a day or two like this big like a
mushroom size yeah like this
I think
what's going to happen is
I think and the reason I think it's
going to be done within a day is because
they don't want to I don't think it's
gonna happen on Friday uh and but I
could be wrong but I don't think it's
gonna happen on Friday because that
would give them that would give Trump
supporters two days to get ready for
something if they did want to like if it
was announced they're not going to do
anything no no I'm not saying they will
I don't know what I am saying is I don't
think that there won't there there will
be uh an indictment that happens this
week I think it happens Monday because
you have to remember they they convene
Monday Wednesday Friday or Monday
Wednesday Thursday so they could also do
it tomorrow and they but we know we know
that they're not convening today now
again we're not I is there any sound
reporting of wine I yesterday
um there was reporting that there was a
bomb threat as the judge gaveled down in
the in a hearing for the decision Civil
Trial our civil
um yeah I don't I don't know if they
gave a reason I mean right now it's like
a currently developing story but what I
will say is
in my non-professional opinion just on
the kind of my like take on this I think
it won't happen this week I think it
happens maybe Monday so that's your
prediction that's my indictment happens
Monday
it happens this it happens Tuesday
Wednesday kind of so here's the next
question then before we go because we're
way over time
um Jack Smith because Jack Smith seems
like he's moving in fast he's moving
fast on him like a [__]
um and it feels like to me that there's
a reason why they're doing that I don't
know that it's because of trump but it's
because of something that Trump has done
or could do
um with something some some of these
something that do with these documents
right and it makes me feel like maybe
he's got a document he shouldn't have or
something's going on something's [__]
weird about how fast this appeal uh the
appeals court is asking for Trump to
provide something and then asking the
doj to rebut right it's a really fast
it's suspicious
um we don't know exactly but it feels
like to me it's fast and in a hurry and
maybe Jack Smith maybe Jack Smith is
trying to be you know the first to this
thing I don't know wouldn't that [__] up
manga if they were like whoa mother I
mean if you're right and they died on
Monday what are Jack Smith's like Monday
morning six o'clock like here's my
indictment [__] unsealed and then uh
Alvin Bragg has to get you know sloppy
seconds on the news I don't know I don't
know he could he could move in we
already know that the the Trump
attorneys uh based on recorded
conversations that Corcoran had are now
being are now trying to be brought in as
evidence uh for Trump knowing and lying
about the the the documents right so
like there's a lot there's a it's like
you know all of these things were slowly
coming in and it's almost like kind of
like gravity in the sense like as you
get closer then the pull becomes
stronger and I think right now you're
seeing that it is going to be like which
one is going to hit Earth like it's
gonna come into the orbit first uh it
could be either of them most likely it's
going to be this indictment that comes
from the Manhattan D.A but who knows I
mean Jack Smith might be like yeah [__]
it we'll throw the Mar-A-Lago documents
case in right now because that's an easy
win based on what we have going against
them so well we'll see tomorrow so we'll
see you tomorrow we'll find out we'll
find out more as the story progresses
and Donald Trump freaks out even more
and more same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon